c'est très difficile à euh à expliquer
car je pense euh qu'il n'y a rien de
vraiment là-bas qui permette
de vivre la même chose
un biplace tu le ressens un peu
mais bien sûr
tu sais que tu as moins d'adhérence la voiture est
plus lourde à cause  aux deux personnes, donc ça
se rapproche,
donc je dirais que c'est probablement la
meilleure sensation que vous puissiez en tirer, mais
de nous
comme même pour moi comme quand j'ai grandi,
bien sûr, j'ai fait du karting et
ensuite vous construisez  ça monte lentement comme si
vous aimiez les voitures de formule inférieure,
puis à un moment donné, vous faites le saut vers la
formule 1 et même pour moi, la première
fois que
j'ai sauté dans une voiture de formule 1, mes yeux
ne pouvaient pas suivre parce que
rappelez-vous comme  quand tu montes sur une voiture de route
ta première vitesse tu accélères ça va
très vite tu sais que ça roule
tu dois changer la seconde
pour moi comme à travers tous les engrenages de la
formule un ça ressemble à ça parce que
ça continue juste à tirer c'est comme ça
ne s'arrête jamais au début  ng bien sûr,
vous vous habituez aux vitesses, je veux dire
comme vous le faites avec une voiture de route la première
fois que vous achetez probablement une voiture de route, votre
nouvelle voiture,
tout semble nouveau et vous aimez un peu vous
habituer, mais ensuite quand vous la
conduisez comme un  année, cela semble normal,
vous savez où tout se trouve,
c'est probablement la même chose dans une voiture de formule 1
,
bien sûr, vous savez quand les
conditions sont difficiles et vous savez que cela peut être un
peu dangereux ou que vous devez être un
peu plus préservé mais pas vraiment peur  mais
vous savez que disons que lorsque vous
conduisez sur le mouillé, la visibilité est un
peu pire, vous savez que
oui, à un moment donné, comme un bon
exemple que j'avais, c'était comme en 2016
au Brésil, euh, nous avons dû faire un
arrêt au stand supplémentaire  euh à cause des
conditions météo on a dû repasser en full wet
et toi tu es en fond de peloton
tu accélères au restart tu
vas dans la ligne droite et il n'y a pas de
visibilité et tu sais que les
gens devant  d'entre vous êtes à fond mais vous
savez aussi que  Si quelqu'un s'écrase
devant vous, vous ne saurez pas où il
est, vous pouvez le frapper de plein fouet
ou vous le manquez et vous ne
savez même pas que quelqu'un est parti, alors ce
genre de situation, vous pensez que
c'est comme ça.  dangereux mais je sais que tout le
monde pousse donc nous devons continuer à pousser
aussi
ouais en fait le fait d'accélérer
est quelque chose comme ce n'est pas la
chose la plus risquée c'est probablement la chose la plus euh et je
veux dire que les voitures sont très sûres je veux dire que
tout va bien  Je pense qu'au fil des années en
général, euh avec la fia, vous
savez que les équipes ont vraiment
amélioré leurs voitures,
bien sûr, cela
dépend un peu de la piste et euh cela
a aussi à voir avec le temps, l'
humidité
de la certaine zone vous
Je suis dedans, mais par exemple la course à Miami, j'ai perdu plus de trois
kilos et demi,
donc c'était difficile parce que toi, le
problème, c'est que tu peux boire un peu, bien sûr,
mais pendant ces
deux heures et demie que tu  Je fais la course, ça
ne sera jamais assez alors
Je veux dire que vous ne pouvez pas faire un arrêt au stand pour
boire ou manger,
donc vous vous sentez toujours vraiment vide à
la fin de la course et surtout
ce genre de courses comme
Singapour à l'époque où la Malaisie était encore
sur le calendrier était le  même chose
parce que c'était pendant la journée aussi donc
c'est vraiment très chaud ouais mais
il y a des courses qui euh comme
probablement comme monza
c'est beaucoup bien sûr
droit beaucoup de lignes droites et ce n'est pas aussi lourd
sur le corps et  vous pourriez perdre un kilo
ou comme un demi-kilo semble toujours énorme
mais oui pour vous je veux dire c'est bon pour
la perte de poids mais d'un autre côté vous
buvez aussi beaucoup après que vous sachiez
bien remettre le corps à niveau et
faire  sûr que vous n'êtes pas déshydraté
alors vous êtes de retour à vos niveaux normaux
si vous voulez perdre du poids être
un pilote de formule 1 n'est probablement pas le
moyen le plus simple pas la plus belle expérience
c'est sûr
[Musique
] beaucoup d'émotions euh juste  pour toute la
saison comment tout  est allé euh mais c'est
aussi bien sûr que
vous connaissez votre objectif de vie dans la
course, je veux dire quand j'étais un petit enfant qui
grandissait à un moment donné, vous savez que vous vous êtes fixé
cet objectif d'essayer de devenir
un pilote de Formule 1, c'est déjà
dur  assez mais alors vous voulez
aussi réussir et
bien sûr que le but ultime est de gagner
un championnat c'est bien de gagner des courses
c'est bien d'être en pole mais c'est bien d'
avoir des podiums mais ce
véritable objectif de gagner un championnat est
quelque chose que vous savez  une fois que vous l'avez
accompli, c'est vraiment un
sentiment incroyable,
je veux dire bien sûr que la
nf1 est très importante pour avoir une
très bonne voiture car je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup de bons pilotes en
Formule 1, mais si vous n'avez pas la
voiture, vous le ferez  ne pas être en mesure de gagner une
présidence, donc c'est sûr que c'est une très
grande partie de cela, je pense que là où le pilote
entre vraiment en jeu et ce qui fait
la différence, c'est dans
des conditions difficiles ou lorsque vous vous
battez vraiment avec une autre équipe
qui  C'est là que vous savez que ces
derniers aiment les pourcentages parce qu'il
y a tellement de bons pilotes dans
le monde, même des gens qui ne sont pas en
Formule 1, vous savez qu'ils peuvent
conduire en endurance mais ils sont
aussi très très très bons et ça  juste à
cause de
la
chance aléatoire ou simplement des circonstances, ils n'ont pas
pu conduire en formule 1,
mais ceux qui sont en formule 1
entre les bons et les très bons sont
comme dans ces moments très décisifs
si c'est une course de pluie ou vous savez dans
des conditions générales très difficiles ou
dans une séance de qualification très importante
pour être là-haut c'est là que vous
pouvez faire la différence ou marquer juste un
peu plus de points que disons que
vous êtes votre coéquipier et avez-vous
envie parce qu'il y a eu plusieurs vous
savez ou vous savez bien sûr les évolutions dans
la façon dont ces réglementations ont
changé pour les voitures et tout, pensez-vous
que c'est une bonne chose et comment voyez-vous
l'évolution
cette année, je pense que
c'est toujours vous  Je sais que vous voyez de
meilleures équipes que d'autres, donc je pense que l'
écart est encore grand, mais je pense que si vous
gardez le règlement euh le même pendant
un certain temps, comme je pense que vous avez vu l'année dernière,
bien sûr, nous trouvions toujours à l'avant,
mais le milieu de terrain le  pack était en fait
très proche, donc je pense qu'avec le temps, ils
se rapprocheraient même du sommet parce que
tout le monde commence à comprendre l'idée
de la façon de développer la voiture et
bien sûr, cela a aussi à voir avec l'argent
et les ressources mais
oui si vous le gardez  la même chose
depuis plus de cinq ans parce que cela
ressemble à une F1, vous avez ce genre de
chose générale où, comme tous les quatre
ou cinq ans, c'est comme un
changement majeur dans la réglementation où nous devons peut-
être arrêter de faire ça euh et puis
lentement les équipes vont  se réunir,
je veux dire que cela dépend bien sûr un peu du
moment où vous avez un double en-tête ou un
triple en-tête ou c'est juste un single comme
un week-end autonome, mais par exemple,
vous savez juste le lundi mardi
mercredi, tout est question de préparation
avant  e vous arrivez même ici euh qui
comprend bien sûr mon programme d'entraînement
surtout maintenant quand il fait très chaud vous
devez bien sûr vous habituer à être
mal à l'aise dans la chaleur disons comme
ça pendant l'entraînement que je
fais
euh ce n'est pas génial mais à  la fin de la
journée, tout le monde doit faire face à ça euh
et puis ouais tu essaies juste de
dépenser le moins d'énergie possible
avant d'entrer dans le week-end tu
sais avec des trucs annexes mis sur la
formule des gardiens c'est le personnel
je veux dire je n'ai jamais vraiment su  n'importe quoi d'
autre parce que dès que j'ai commencé à
courir comme
ça, c'est ma vie à courir
bien sûr à l'époque où vous deviez aller à l'
école aussi mais euh de
nos jours je veux dire je rentre à la maison et je
sais juste ce que je fais depuis  depuis
longtemps maintenant et vous voulez bien sûr
rattraper vos amis famille vous savez essayer de leur
accorder de l'attention et bien sûr vous
savez juste essayer de vous détendre un peu aussi à la
maison
parce que vous voyagez tellement
et c'est sûr que cela a augmenté au fil des ans  temps  en
formule un aussi euh tu voles
beaucoup plus pour courir plus loin
euh et surtout aussi avec le calendrier qui
devient de plus en plus gros
c'est plus un défi mais
ouais tu dois juste essayer de gérer
ça alors tu fais d'habitude  voyagez avec des
amis ou de la famille comme vous êtes seul
ou avec votre équipe comment faites-vous cela
dépend un peu parfois quelques personnes
rejoignent bien sûr mon manager et mon père
ils ont rejoint comme 50 50
chacun euh donc c'est bien tu sais avoir
les gens autour de moi, bien sûr, je peux facilement le
faire moi-même en voyageant pour les courses,
mais
je pense que c'est aussi bien d'avoir juste des
amis ou de la famille près de toi,
je veux dire que tu dois toujours essayer de vivre
aussi normalement que tu peux être mais de  Bien sûr, je
sais que, euh,
comme à l'époque, je reviendrais à l'époque
où ma famille vivait encore et vous pourriez le
savoir, comme marcher dans la
rue et manger un bon morceau ou
quoi que ce soit, je sais que c'est un peu
plus difficile je sais que ça peut sonner un
peu comme bien quoi  est le problème, mais
bien sûr, parfois, c'est agréable de
passer du temps avec la famille et les amis sans se
faire remarquer ou ne pas être dérangé, disons,
je sais que les gens veulent bien dire qu'ils
veulent juste une photo ou un autographe, mais
parfois je ne veux pas être reconnu.
et juste passer du temps avec ma famille, euh,
mais c'est bon si vous savez que
ces choses sont le seul vrai problème,
alors je ne peux pas me plaindre,
cela fait partie du travail, je sais que
bien sûr, parfois, j'aimerais pouvoir
retourner à la  des jours où vous n'étiez
pas vraiment connu et vous pouviez simplement faire
votre truc ouais je comprends
la formule
je veux dire je connais certains de ces pilotes
bien sûr déjà depuis longtemps nous
aimons essentiellement grandi ensemble à travers le
sport automobile donc naturellement vous avez plus
de  une connexion avec eux et ouais c'est
sympa bien sûr sur la piste on essaie toujours de
se battre mais tu sais on a aussi une
bonne relation en dehors de la piste
et parfois on essaie de se rencontrer un
peu parce qu'avec certains tu as un  un
peu d'une meilleure connexion
naturellement, mais oui, tout le monde a un
emploi du temps très chargé, donc même se rencontrer
parfois n'est pas le plus facile et euh avec
votre coéquipier à la caisse
aujourd'hui, comment voyez-vous votre relation
parce que les gens qui ne connaissent pas la formule
un pensent que vous savez  comme des coéquipiers mais
en même temps vous courez tous les deux
bien sûr pour gagner des courses comment posez-vous cette
question euh cette année ouais mais je veux dire
c'est pareil dans le football non je veux dire
bien sûr vous voyez l'équipe 11 joueurs
sur le terrain mais là  il y a aussi des gens
sur le banc qui essaient d'obtenir cette
place et mais à la fin de la journée,
vous travaillez toujours pour l'équipe et
vous voulez avoir le meilleur résultat et
c'est exactement comme ça que nous le faisons aussi je
veux dire je pense que nous  travailler très bien
ensemble, nous avons une bonne relation
aussi en dehors de la piste, vous savez que nous pouvons avoir des
conversations sur n'importe quoi et
parfois c'est vraiment agréable parce que vous
n'avez pas besoin de parler de course et vous
pouvez simplement parler d'autres choses et ouais
il '  c'est un mec super euh
et c'est bien aussi pour l'équipe
quand les deux pilotes s'entendent bien
bien sûr et une dernière question
à ce sujet il y a une rumeur disant
qu'il y a comme une sorte de groupe whatsapp
avec tous les pilotes ensemble c'est une
vraie chose  ouais ça l'est mais c'est principalement
juste pour parler euh
euh de trucs de course parce que bien sûr
nous avons le gpda donc où tous les
pilotes sont unis euh et vous savez nous avons
parlé à la faa nous parlons bien sûr à
fom aussi f1 euh tu sais  pour
aussi qu'ils comprennent notre point de vue
et c'est pourquoi bien sûr nous avons le
groupe WhatsApp que vous connaissez afin que nous puissions
discuter de choses
je pense que dans l'ensemble la f1 est vraiment occupée avec
euh avec ces choses parce que si vous voyez
où nous sommes arrivés  à partir de et avec quoi
nous courons maintenant, je pense que le
moteur est incroyablement efficace, vous savez,
par rapport à certaines voitures et
en fin de compte, c'est toute la technologie
qui aidera le monde parce qu'en
fin de compte, beaucoup de choses qui  a
été  développé en formule 1 est maintenant dans
votre voiture actuelle, donc vous savez parfois,
bien sûr, on dirait que nous ne sommes
pas les plus verts, mais en
fin de compte, nous apprenons aussi beaucoup
de choses pour l'avenir
et faisons  vous avez l'impression que c'est quelque chose qui
est venu de plus en plus au cours des dernières années
et vous entendez de plus en plus dans le je
pense que cela a toujours été là, mais bien sûr,
les dernières années ont
probablement
accéléré encore plus, ce qui, je pense, est
bon parce que nous avons besoin  pour faire quelque chose que nous
devons bien sûr continuer à améliorer et
continuer à essayer d'être meilleur euh pour le monde
en général et pourquoi vous savez ne pas partir
d'un pour vraiment essayer de trouver de bonnes
solutions c'est super merci
beaucoup merci c'est tellement cool